LAST NIGHT.
THREE GOALS TO THE CAPITAL SPEED
TOOLS.
GOODROW.E WAS
SAVE.IT'S A POWER PLAY GOAL.
HE'S GOING TO GET IT RIGHT IN
PUBLIC.
KAKKO REACHES FOR IT. TO CLEAR.
FOX'S GOT TO HUSTLE..
THE E GAME.
REALLYROBINSON TRYING TO CLEAR S
OWN.
NEMETH HAD A STICK ON IT TO KEEP
IT TAND SPACE.
A LITTLE BIT TOO MUCH.FRONT OFFR
TWICE.
BUT GOALS FOR THE RANGERS.
TOO MUCUC
THEY GOT MOVING.
TWO THE GLOVE ON IT
AND HOLDS.
CORNER.
ROONEY EMPLOYED
HERE BY HEAD COACH GERARD
GALLANT.
PUCKSZONE.
THERE'S NOT MUCH YOU CAN DO.
HE IS SMART, GREAT EDGES.
ELVIS WILL DEAL.
NYQUIST, ONE-TIY
TEXIER WITH THE PUBLIC.
KNOCKED OFF NEMETH AND TEXIER.
NEMETH, NO QUESTION13:15.
5:30 LEFT, TO G